Despite technical progress, adoption of
PHRs and other tools for patients remains an issue.
A recent paper suggests that current adoption is around 20% to 30% of
patients but forecasts say the majority of patients will use a PHR by 2020.
There are several challenges to adoption: getting the data to patients,
privacy concerns, patient engagement, and usability.
We will cover each of these at a high level.
For more, I refer you to a recent paper that discusses PHRs
and their challenges in some detail.
Once again, interoperability is a key issue.
Absent it, how does PHR data get into a patient's personal record?
This becomes even more problematic if they receive care from
several providers that we have learned patients with
multiple chronic diseases typically do.
The most common form of personal health record is a browser-based patient portal.
Enterprise software vendors often supply portals and automatically
populate them with data from their EHR and their other clinical systems.
Here is an example of a modern patient portal provided by
Marshfield Clinic Information Services (MCIS).
This company is a spin-out from the Marshfield Clinic,
one of the most highly regarded health systems in
the US and an advanced user of informatics.
Note that it brings together a patient's health record,
reminders of needed tests and procedures,
messaging, and even financial and administrative services.
One of the key goals of meaningful use is to ensure that patients have
electronic access to their records no matter where they receive their care.
In fact, meaningful use has a term for this: view,
download, and transmit or VDT.
And it's a key measure for providers.
In Stage Two, more than 50% of all unique patients seen during
each 90-day reporting period must have had timely access to the health information.
More than 5% must have actually used this capability.
The second measure seems designed to incent providers to
explain their VDT tool and encourage their patients to use it.
Some research suggests that this provider engagement is effective.
There are also meaningful use measures related to
sharing of health data at transitions of care.
Continuity of care document or CCD is an HL7-specified,
XML-formatted electronic patient summary and is one way to meet this requirement.
As you will see in the health fault exercise that follows,
it's also a way for a patient to easily load
all their EHR data from all their providers into a PHR.
The second challenge is patient concerns about
the loss of privacy if their health data is stored in the cloud.
In a 2008 Markle Foundation survey of 1,580 adults,
77% reported privacy concerns related to misuse of personal data by marketeers,
56% expressed concerns about misuse by employers,
and 53% had similar concerns about health insurers.
The Affordable Care Act provision outlawing the use of preexisting conditions to deny
health insurance may have alleviated
these concerns to some degree with respect to health insurers.
However, with data breaches increasingly common,
including in health care,
this issue is likely to remain a serious challenge.
Finally, there is the challenge of getting patients to use these tools.
Several studies have asked patients what functions they most want from a PHR.
Unsurprisingly, these include access to
their past medical history including immunizations, lab tests,
and medications, as well as access to their appointments,
and communication with their providers.
Patients often want to access their family member's records.
Age, lack of computer literacy,
and unfamiliarity with medical terminology are often impediments to PHR use.
You'll have an opportunity to explore these challenges and
usability in particular in the exercise that follows.